félicite également très sincèrement mon
ancien collègue l'ambassadeur volkan
bosquet qui assume maintenant la
présidence de l'assemblée générale
l'élection de l'ambassadeur beauce cuir
à ce poste avec l'appui de la majorité
écrasante des pays membres est la preuve
de ses excellentes qualités personnelles
et de son expérience remarquable en tant
que diplomate et politique de la turquie
en tant que premier citoyen turc à
assumer cette position à hautes
responsabilités au sein du système des
nations unies je suis convaincu que
l'ambassadeur beauce cuir sera la voix
et la conscience de la communauté
internationale je suis convaincu qu il
s'acquittera de son mandat de façon
juste et transparente
je souhaite plein de succès à monsieur
beauce kir
il assume ses fonctions à une date
remarquable le 75e anniversaire de la
fondation des nations unies je pense que
la tenue de l'assemblée générale
sous le thème lutter contre la copie de
19 et lutter pour le multilatéralisme
est une bonne décision en tant que pays
thur que nous honorons nos engagements
et nous avons l'intention de continuer
notre lutte contre le virus
la pandémie nous a frappés alors que
nous nous étions déjà à différentes
difficultés la mondialisation le système
international fondé sur les règles et le
multilatéralisme était déjà sous le feu
des projecteurs et sont encore plus
remis en question suite à la pandémie
alors que nous nous attelons à la
situation face à nous nous devons
regarder il le verre est à moitié plein
ou à moitié vide
s'agissant enfin du côté évident du
verre il convient de réformer les
organisations multilatérales plus
particulièrement l'onu nous avons vu à
quel point les mécanismes internationaux
ont été inefficaces pendant cette crise
il a fallu des semaines voire des mois
au conseil de sécurité l'organe le plus
important pour la prise
de décision aux nations unies pour
inclure la pandémie à son ordre du jour
haut débit de là au début de la pandémie
nous avons vu des pays laissés pour
compte
voilà pourquoi nous estimons qu'il
convient de reconnaître que le monde ce
n'est pas cinq grands acteurs
c'est ce que nous plaidons depuis de
nombreuses années du haut de cette
tribune le sort de l'humanité ne peut
reposer dans les mains d'un nombre
restreint de pays afin d'éviter que nos
organisations internationales ne voient
leur réputation ternie
nous devons revoir nos mentalités nos
règles et nos institutions à
multilatéralisme efficace nécessite des
institutions multilatérales
efficaces nous devons procéder à des
réformes globales et de fond à commencer
par une restructuration du conseil de
sécurité nous devons doter le conseil
d'une structure et d'un fonctionnement
plus efficace plus démocratique plus
transparent et plus responsable de la
même façon nous devons renforcer
l'assemblée générale l'assemblée
générale doit refléter la conscience
commune de la communauté internationale
s'agissant du côté plaint du verre l'onu
a conservé son potentiel
l'onu est le point vers lequel
l'humanité se tourner en quête de paix
de justice et de prospérité
étant donné qu'il nous reste encore à
surmonter cette pandémie
nous devons tenter d'utiliser les
institutions et les mécanismes ainsi que
la coopération multilatérale de la façon
la plus efficace possible
lorsque les problèmes sont
internationaux les solutions locales ne
sont qu'un emplâtre sur une jambe de
bois
la solidarité internationale est
nécessaire à des solutions à long terme
en turquie depuis le début de la flambée
de la crise nous avons appelé à une
coopération au sein de toutes les
plateformes internationales
nous sommes en première ligne des
efforts de lutte contre la pandémie au
sein du g20 au sein du conseil turc
ursea qu'au sein de l'habitat de
l'organisation de coopération islamique
et au sein d'autres plateformes
nous avons contacté 146 pays et cette
organisation internationale ayant fait
des demandes d'assistance médicale en
sachant que l'on peut compter sur ses
vrais amis en temps de difficultés
s'agissant des opérations de
rapatriement nous avons garanti leur
trouvera de près de cent mille de nos
citoyens en provenance de 141 pays avec
ces mêmes vols nous avons transporté
cinq mille cinq cents ressortissants
étrangers vers 67 de leur pays
nous n'avons pas agi dans l'intention de
mener une diplomatie et du cornât virus
nous n'attendons aucun dédommagement
dans le cadre de nos efforts
d'assistance ou de rapatriement nous
sommes solidaires avec les victimes
c'est dans notre essence dont l'essence
de notre nation et de notre politique
étrangère humanitaire encore une fois
j'appelle à ce que les traitements
médicaux les vaccins et les efforts de
développement ne fassent pas l'objet de
concurrence peu importe le pays chargés
de la production du vaccin
les vaccins devront être fournis pour le
bien de l'ensemble de l'humanité
mesdames et messieurs les délégués à
cause de la pandémie nous avons pu
comprendre à quel point les capacités de
l'état la bonne gouvernance et la
résilience sont importantes
le succès de la turquie repose dans des
mécanismes de gouvernance efficace que
nous avons pu établir 4 grâce à notre
système de gouvernement présidentielle
nous avons une capacité est élevé
d'investissements dans les
infrastructures dans le secteur de la
santé nous disposons de ressources
humaines qualifiées
cela étant dit la pandémie a eu des
effets néfastes sur les dynamiques de
conflits à travers le monde et à
exacerber les vulnérabilités
nous déplorons que l'appel du secrétaire
général des nations unies en faveur d'un
cessez-le-feu humanitaire internationale
que vous
appuyons soit restée lettre morte
la turquie va chercher des moyens
d'éliminer les menaces qui pèsent sur
notre pays et l'humanité en adoptant
toutes les initiatives nécessaires
le conflit en série entame sa dixième
année et constituent encore une menace
qui pèse sur la sécurité la stabilité de
notre région en tant que pays qui a
frappé le plus durement dash dans la
région nous continuons également notre
lutte contre le pays l'organisation
terroriste pkk en tant que communauté
internationale nous ne pourrons trouver
de solution permanente à la question
syrienne sont adoptées des mesures de
principe et une opposition ferme contre
les organisations terroristes
il en va de même pour garantir le retour
sûr et volontaire vers la syrie le
retour de prêt de 400 11000 frères et
soeurs syrien vers les régions que nous
avons libéré du terrorisme en syrie est
la preuve la plus parlante de cela de la
même façon
grâce aux régions que nous avons pu
sécuriser nous nous sommes assurés que
des millions de syriens vivent dans
différentes régions du pays
particulièrement ils libres puissent
être en sécurité la turquie accueille
près de 4 millions de syriens sur son
territoire depuis des années et répond à
tous leurs besoins
nous répondons également aux besoins
d'un nombre similaire de syriens dans le
pays
sur le terrain dans des régions que nous
contrôlons plus particulièrement à
proximité de nos frontières
en fin de compte nous construisons
construisons des dizaines de milliers
d'abris à idlib pour nos frères et nos
soeurs nous menons toutes ses activités
avec nos propres ressources avec l'appui
de notre population sans véritable appui
de la communauté internationale ou des
organisations internationales
nous devrions tous de façon prioritaire
régler le conflit en syrie sur la base
de la feuille de route entériné par la
résolution 22 54 du conseil de sécurité
à cette fin le processus politique lancé
un sous l'égide des nations unies
processus qui est également menée par et
pour les syriens devraient être
couronnée de succès ce n'est que de
cette façon que la syrie pourra se
lancer sur la voie de la paix durable
tout en conservant son intégrité
territoriale et son unité politique en
attente de la réalisation de cet
objectif nous avons l'intention
d'empêcher les organisations terroristes
qui menacent notre sécurité nationale et
notre unité politique et l'intégrité
territoriale de la syrie de d'opérer
aujourd'hui des pays tels que la turquie
accueille en nombre élevé de réfugiés
contribuer à sauver la dignité de
l'humanité grâce à ces sacrifices
toutefois certains états y compris
certains pays européens violent
malheureusement les droits des réfugiés
des demandeurs d'asile
l'heure est venue pour l'organisation
des nations unies de se prononcer
fermement entre ces violations qui sape
la convention de genève et le système
international des droits de la personne
les attaques fomentées par les fauteurs
de troubles en libye l'année dernière
visant à renverser le gouvernement
d'accord national n'ont apporté que
souffrances et destructions au pays
la communauté internationale n'a pu
s'assurer que les fauteurs de troubles
où leurs apps lui rendre des comptes
pour les massacres les violations des
droits de la personne encore les
différentes tombe d'été rld est déterrée
à tarhouna la turquie est le seul pays
qui a prévu une réponse concrète et qui
répondent aux appels du gouvernement
légitime de la libye
nous estimons qu'une solution permanente
politique en libye est possible grâce à
un dialogue inclusif et complet mené par
les libyens
il en va également de la responsabilité
de la communauté internationale de
mettre fin au bain de sang au yémen qui
perdure depuis plus de cinq ans il
convient de mettre fin à cette crise
humanitaire l'histoire n'oubliera pas
ceux qui ont convoité la souveraineté du
yémen son unité politique son intégrité
territoriale afin d'obtenir une
influence dans la région
nous n'oublierons pas non plus ceux qui
ont fermé les yeux sur les souffrances
de la population yéménite nous espérons
véritablement que l'irak ne deviendra
pas une zone de conflit de puissance
pour les puissances extérieures et
pourra se lancer sur la voie de la
stabilité et de la prospérité pour le
bien de notre région
nous appuyons notre voisin irakien dans
tous les domaines et nous espérons
coopérer plus étroitement dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme
nous comptons sur une coopération
sincère avec la communauté
internationale et l'irak en ce qui
concerne l'éradication de l'organisation
terroriste pkk qui est abrité en irak
comme cela a été le cas pour des shs
libérer la région des organisations
terroristes contribuera à un avenir
riche pour l'irak qui est le lieu de
l'origine de notre humanité
nous voulons régler les questions du
programme nucléaire iranien grâce au
droit international la diplomatie et le
dialogue
je rappelle à toutes les parties
qu'elles doivent s'acquitter de leurs
obligations au titre du plan d'action
global comment qui contribuent
véritablement la sécurité régionale et
internationale le régime d'occupation et
d'oppression en palestine qui est une
plaie ouverte pour notre humanité touche
véritablement ne
conscience les puissants à ceux qui
convoitent jérusalem un lieu sacré pour
nos trois grandes religions de cesse de
faire montre d'audace la population
palestinienne s'opposent depuis près de
50 ans aux politiques et d'oppression de
violence et d'intimidation d'israël en
refusant de se rendre au nom de l'accord
du siècle la palestine se heurte
maintenant à israël qui tentent
d'accélérer certaines mesures internes
avec l'aide de ses alliés la turquie a
appuyé la population parle palestinienne
et appuie appuie les plans d' accord
accepté par la population palestinienne
la participation de certains pays de la
région à ce jeu ne sert que les efforts
d'israël visant à saper les paramètres
du droit international les pays qui ont
fait part de leur intention d'ouvrir des
ambassades à jérusalem en violation des
résolutions de l'onu du droit
international ne font que compliquer le
conflit le conflit palestinien saura
être résolue qu'avec la création d'un
état de palestine indépendant souverain
et continue sur la base des frontières
de 1967 avec jérusalem est comme
capitale
tenter de trouver d'autres solutions et
20 unilatérale est totalement injuste
l'arménie a attaqué les territoires de
l'azerbaïdjan en juillet et a à nouveau
démontré que l est le véritable obstacle
qui s'élève sur la voie d'une paix
durable et de la stabilité dans le
caucase du sud
nous voulons résoudre les conflits de la
région le plus rapidement possible et
plus particulièrement le conflit du
nagorno-karabakh conformément à
l'intégrité territoriale la souveraineté
de l'azerbaïdjan et de la géorgie et
conformément aux résolutions des nations
unies et de l'osce
le conflit au cachemire est également la
clé de la stabilité et de la paix en
asie du sud
et c'est encore un problème pressant les
mesures prises suite à l'abolition du
statut spécial de déjà du jammu
cachemire le font qu'exacerber les
difficultés nous voulons régler ses
problèmes grâce au dialogue dans le
cadre des résolutions des nations unies
et surtout en respectant les attentes de
la population du cachemire mesdames et
messieurs les délégués derrière les
tensions que l'on constate dans l'est de
la méditerranée
il s'agit en fait de mesures visant à
tout emporter
les tentatives futiles d'exclure notre
pays sont vouées à l'échec
nous n'avons pas d'autres intérêts que
les nôtres
en ce qui concerne l'est de la
méditerranée au d'autres régions
toutefois nous ne pouvons pas fermer les
yeux sur les violations des droits de
notre pays et des droits des chypriotes
turcs ou encore nous pouvons ignorer que
nos intérêts sont foulées aux pieds elle
a raison des problèmes dans la région
sont dues aux mesures unilatérales
prises par la grèce et les chypriotes
grecs depuis 2003
la turquie est un pays qui doit assumer
le fardeau d'une évolution négative de
la situation dans l'est de la
méditerranée
d'un autre côté on ne saurait expliquer
que l'on ignore un pays
pour ce qui est de ses ressources
naturelles dont la région cela ne peut
s'expliquer ni par la sagesse ou la
conscience ou le droit international
notre priorité de régler les différends
grâce à un dialogue sincère sur la base
du droit international et sur un pied
d'égalité toutefois nous ne tolèrerons
aucune mesure imposiez aucun harcèlement
où aucune attaque
je le répète je répète notre app
elle en faveur d'un dialogue et de la
coopération entre les pays côtiers de
l'est de la méditerranée
à cette fin nous aimerions proposer la
tenue d'une conférence régionale
comprenant les chypriotes turcs où l'on
examinera les droits et les intérêts de
tous les pays de la région une des
raisons qui explique la crise dans la
région c'est l'absence de solution juste
globale et permanente à la question
chypriote
depuis les négociations qui ont ils se
tiennent de façon intermittente
intermittente depuis 1968
l'obstacle à une solution c'est la
proche injustes et sans compromis de la
partie chypriote grecque en faisant fi
des accords internationaux la partie
chypriote grecque a pour objectif de
faire des chypriotes turcs une minorité
dans leur patrie ou même de les exclure
totalement de l'île en tant que pays
garants nous n'allons jamais abandonné
la population chypriote turque
nous n'abandonnerons pas leur cause
juste nous ne les abandonnerons pas à
l'avenir la solution à la question
chypriote est possible si l'on reconnaît
que les chypriotes turcs sont les
copropriétaires de lille nous appuierons
toute solution qui permettra de garantir
de façon permanente la sécurité de la
population chypriote turque ainsi que
leurs droits politiques et historiques
sur l'île
mesdames et messieurs les délégués
cette année nous commémorons le 75e
anniversaire des bombardements atomiques
d'hiroshima et de nagasaki le
désarmement est vital pour garantir la
paix et la sécurité internationales
nous constatons que les dispositifs de
contrôle d'armes au mans en fait l'objet
de coups lourds et ces dernières années
la communauté internationale doit aller
de l'avant sur un pied d'égalité et dans
la justice afin d'éliminer toutes les
armes de destruction massive
autre question importante pour laquelle
nous devons agir de façon commune ce
sont les changements climatiques
nous constatons que l'ingérence humaine
dans la nature à des coûts immenses
nous devons faire machine arrière la
turquie a puis sincèrement les efforts
en la matière et s'acquitte de ses
obligations
même si nous n'avons quasiment aucune
responsabilité historique
par le passé nous avons accueilli la
conférence des parties à la convention
des nations unies de lutte contre la
désertification
nous avons mené une coopération
fructueuse avec bien des régions et pays
plus particulièrement en afrique
nous avons également prévu d'accueillir
la 16e conférence des parties à la
convention sur la diversité biologique
en 2022
j'aimerais maintenant attirer votre
attention sur un problème qui menace
l'humanité mais qui pour une certaine
raison est ignoré le racisme la
xénophobie et l'islamophobie et les
discours haineux ont atteint des niveaux
alarmants
pendant la pandémie
les actes de violence à l'encontre de
personnes vulnérables plus
particulièrement l'encontre de migrants
et de demandeurs d'asile augmenté alors
que la xénophobie et le racisme ont pris
de l'ampleur
les musulmans sont ceux qui courent le
plus de risques face à cette tendance
dangereuse du aux préjugés et
l'ignorance les principaux responsables
de cette tendance dangereuse sont les
responsables politiques qui font le
choix de discours populiste pour obtenir
des voix
et dépend marginalisés de la population
en légitimant le discours haineux ou en
abusant de la liberté d'expression
j'exhorte les organisations
internationales à prendre des mesures
plus concrètes pour lutter contre cette
mentalité je réitère à gérer terme
l'appel du 15 mars le jour de l'attaqué
terroriste perpétrée en nouvelle zélande
contre des musulmans afin que c'est du
jour on est soit déclarée par les
nations unies comme journée
internationale de solidarité contre
l'islamophobie en tant que deuxième
organisation la plus grande au monde
après l'onu l'organisation de la
coopération islamique a officiellement
reconnu cette journée la pandémie et la
crise économique croissante qui
l'accompagnent ont eu des effets
négatifs sur le développement durable et
nos objectifs à l'horizon 2030 les pays
en développement les pays à faibles
revenus sont les plus touchés par cette
crise
de fait ce qu'il ya eu lieu pendant la
pandémie nous a démontré que les
objectifs du développement durable
peuvent être un phare pour lutter contre
bien des crises internationales
nous devons également utiliser la
numérisation pour retrouver des
solutions économiques à cette crise et
changer la donne nous appuyons la
feuille de route du secrétaire général
en faveur d'une coopération numérique
nous avons également annoncé le premier
forum diplomatique d'antalya qui fera le
choix d'aborder les questions régionales
et internationales sous l'angle de la
diplomatie à l'ère du numérique
nous accueillons également la banque d'
échanges technologiques des nations
unies pour les pays les moins avancés en
tant que pays européens se trouvant le
plus à l'est et en tant que pays
asiatiques se trouvant le plus à l'ouest
nous avons un véritable poids dans tous
les secteurs avec notre initiative
d'asie renouveler nous allons 2
un nouveau dynamisme à leur relation
alors que l' équilibre de l'histoire
penche maintenant vers l'asie nous avons
également renforcer une relation avec
l'afrique avec laquelle nous entretenons
des liens humanitaire et historique
ainsi qu'une proximité géographique nous
avons l'intention de mener à bien des
programmes visant à renforcer les
capacités de l'afrique et ce dans le
cadre de notre semaine de partenariat
turquie union africaine qui se tiendra
en turquie l'année prochaine alors que
je clos mon intervention
j'aimerais vous dire que j'appuie
fermement le multilatéralisme et que cet
appui sera infaillible alors que nous
traversons ses terres difficiles nous
devons garder le cap pour nous éloigner
de cette pandémie
nous devons également serrer les rangs
et renforcer notre coopération pour
relever tous les défis qui menacent la
communauté internationale nous allons
poursuivre nos efforts visant à
transformer istanbul une des plus
grandes villes de l'histoire nous
voulons faire d'istanbul un centre
régional des nations unies je vous
souhaite plein succès à l'occasion de
cette 75e assemblée générale au nom de
mon pays et de moi même je vous salue et
je vous souhaite pleine santé
homeland au nom de l'assemblée générale
je remercie le président de la
république de turquie pour l'allocution
qu'il vient